OUT SOONER RATHER THAN LATER.
SOMETHING IS GOING ON.
IT’S VERY STRANGE.
>> Sean: EARLIER THIS WEEK, YOU
CALLED JOE BIDEN A TROJAN HORSE
FOR SOCIALISM.
A PUPPET OF LEFT WING EXTREMISTS
TRYING TO TAKE AWAY OUR ENERGY.
THAT RAISES A QUESTION THAT
MEDIA DEMOCRATS BROUGHT UP ABOUT
REAGAN IN 1984 AND JOHN McCAIN
IN 2008.
DO YOU SEE JOE BIDEN, YOU ARE
THE PRESIDENT.
I LOOK AT HIM FROM 4 YEARS AGO.
HE SEEMS FRAIL AND WEAK TO ME.
I HAVE BEEN VERY OUTSPOKEN ABOUT
IT.
YOUR JOB IS THE TOUGHEST JOB
FROM MY POSITION IN THE WORLD.
DO YOU SEE SOMEBODY WHO HAS THE
STAMMINA AND MENTAL ALERTNESS
FOR THAT JOB?
>> WELL, I DON’T WANT TO GET
INTO.
IT’S OBVIOUS WHAT IS GOING ON.
WHEN YOU ARE DEALING WITH
PRESIDENT XI OF CHINA AND
PRESIDENT PUTTON  -- PUTIN AND
ERDOGAN.
YOU ARE DEALING WITH THESE
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE VERY SHARP.
THEY ARE AT THE TOP OF THEIR
GAME.
IF YOU ARE NOT AT THE TOP OF
YOUR GAME, IT WON’T BE A PRETTY
PICTURE.
IF YOU ARE NOT A GREAT CHESS
MASTER, YOU WILL HAVE A PROBLEM.
THAT WE DON’T THINK HE IS.
ONE THING YOU LEFT OFF YOUR LIST
IS HE WANTS TO TAKE AWAY, THEY
WILL TAKE AWAY WITHOUT QUESTION
YOUR SECOND AMENDMENT.
THAT’S WITHOUT QUESTION.
I HAVE BEEN FIGHTING THAT
SUCCESSFULLY.
IT’S NOT GOING ANYWHERE WITH ME
HERE.
WE HAVE GOOD PEOPLE.
KEVIN MCCARTHY IS GREAT.
WE HAVE SOME GREAT PEOPLE
FIGHTING FOR US.
BUT THE SECOND AMENDMENT IS
GONE.
FORGET ABOUT IT IF WE LOSE AND
YOUR TAXES WILL BE DOUBLED AND
TRIPLED.
JOBS WILL BE GONE.
YOU WILL HAVE A DEPRESSION IF
THAT HAPPENS.
IT’S THE BIGGEST HEAD WIND.
WE SET A NEW RECORD IN THE STOCK
MARKET.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN MUCH HIGHER.
THAT’S DURING THE PANDEMIC WHEN
I HOPE IS NEARING THE FINAL
TURN.
THE BIGGEST HEADWIND IS IF HE
GOT IN.
JUST LIKE LAST TIME.
WE WON IT AND IT WENT UP LIKE
A ROCKET SHIP AFTER THE
ELECTION.
401KS WILL GO UP BUT THEY WILL
GO DOWN 50% IF HE GETS IN.
ALL OF THIS STUFF YOU TALKED
ABOUT WILL KILL OUR COUNTRY AND
THE ECONOMY.
>> Sean: HOUSING STARTS.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I DIDN’T
THINK AFTER THE SHUTDOWN JOBS
WOULD COME BACK AS QUICKLY AS
THEY CAME BACK.
>> RIGHT, RECORD SETTING.
>> Sean: HOUSING STARTS.
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE.
ALL OF THE INDICATIONS.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING FOR THIS
THIRD QUARTER?
>> I THINK WE WILL HAVE A GREAT
FOURTH QUARTER AND HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE NEXT YEAR.
YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS AND THEY
ARE RECORD SETTING.
OVER 9 MILLION JOBS.
THAT’S WITH A MINIMUM OF
STIMULUS.
THE DEMOCRATS DON’T WANT TO
APPROVE STIMULUS FOR PEOPLE.
THEY JUST WANT BAIL OUT MONEY
FOR THEIR GOVERNORS WHO HAVE
DONE SO BADLY IN NEW YORK AND
ILLINOIS.
HE’S DONE A TRADITIONAL JOB IN
THEY ARE HAVING A HARD TIME IN
CALIFORNIA.
ALTHOUGH HE’S TREATED ME VERY
NICELY SO I WILL TREAT HIM
NICELY BUT THEY ARE HAVING
A HARD TIME.
THEY WANT BAIL OUT MONEY IN
OTHER DEMOCRAT RUN STATES.
REPUBLICANS ARE DOING ARE.
REPUBLICAN STATES ARE DOING
GREAT.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS HAPPENING.
THIS IS LONG-TERM.
THIS IS NOT JUST OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS.
THIS IS FOR MANY, MANY YEARS.
THEY WANT TO USE COVID-19 OR THE
CHINA PLAYING TO GET BAIL OUT
MONEY.
>> Sean: BARACK OBAMA SAID YOU
HAVE SHOWN NO INTEREST IF
PUTTING IN THE WORK.
HE IS ACTING LIKE THEY GO LOW
AND WE GO HIGH.
I DIDN’T SEE THE HIGH IN HIS
SPEECH OR MICHELLE OBAMA’S
SPEECH.
YOUR REACTION TO BOTH OF THEIR
SPEECHES?
ONE THING YOU SAID THAT
INTERESTED ME YOU BELIEVE THEY
PAVED THE WAY FOR YOU TO BE
ELECTED?
>> WITHOUT THEM, WITHOUT BIDEN
AND OBAMA, I WOULD NOT BE
PRESIDENT.
THEY WERE SO BAD.
PEOPLE DON’T REMEMBER THE HATRED
AND DIVISION.
THERE WAS TESTIMONY DIVISION.
-- TREMENDOUS DIVISION.
A LITTLE MORE QUIET BUT IT WAS
TREMENDOUS HATRED AND DIVISION
WE HAD FOR 8 YEARS.
HE WAS A TERRIBLE PRESIDENT.
HE WAS A VERY DIVISIVE
PRESIDENT.
WE HAD THE SLOWEST RECOVERY IN
THE HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY FROM
1929 LET’S SAY.
THE GREAT DEPOSITION.
-- DEPRESSION.
IT WAS THE SLOWEST RECOVERY WE
EVER HAD.
WHEN A GOT IN, IT WAS A ROCKET
SHAPE.
WE DWAYNE WADE.
-- GAINED.
NOW THE STOCK MARKET, NASDAQ IS
HIRE AND THE REST WILL BE
HIGHER.
WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT’S
POSSIBLE?
WHILE WE ARE GOING THROUGH THIS
PROBLEM CAUSED BY CHINA.
>> Sean: YOU SAID THE ONLY WAY
THAT CAN WINS A RIGGED ELECTION.
THE WHOLE ISSUE OF MAIL-IN
BALLOTS.
THE HERITAGE FOUNDATION SAMPLING
FRAUD ACROSS THE COUNTRY THEY
FOUND 1,088 CASES OF PROVEN
VOTER FRAUD.
A WEST VIRGINIA MAIL CARRIER WAS
NABBED IN A SCHEME.
CALIFORNIA VOTER FRAUD EXPOSED
THE SKID ROW SCHEME.
AND ILLINOIS LET NON-CITIZEN
REGISTER TO VOTE THERE.
ALABAMA ABSENTEE BALLOTS FRAUD
IN 2019.
A WISCONSIN COUNTY SUPERVISOR
ADMITED TO BALLOT FRAUD.
THE WIFE OF A MAYORAL CANDIDATE
NABBED IN NEW MEXICO.
DOUBLE VOTING IN ARIZONA.
1,088 PROVEN CASES OF VOTER
FRAUD.
>> IT’S A DISASTER AND WILL BE
NO MATTER HOW YOU LOOK AT IT.
THEY ARE SENDING OUT 51 MILLION
BALLOTS TO PEOPLE WHO DIDN’T ASK
FOR THEM.
ABSENTEE BALLOTS ARE GREAT.
I USED ONE FOR FLORIDA.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN FLORIDA USE
THEM.
THAT’S WHEN YOU GO THROUGH
A PROCESS.
YOU ASK FOR IT AND IT’S VERY
SECURE.
THERE IS NOTHING LIKE GOING TO
THE VOTER’S BOOTH AND WE SHOULD
HAVE VOTER I.D. WHEN THE
DEMOCRATS DON’T WANT, WITH YOUR
PICTURE ON IT.
ABSENTEE IS GOOD.
THEY WANT UNIVERSAL MAIL-IN
BALLOTS.
51 MILLION BALLOTS SENT TO WHO
KNOWS WHO?
WHERE ARE THEY GOING?
THIS WILL BE THE GREATEST SCAM
IN HISTORY.
THIS WILL BE THE MOST FRAUDULENT
ELECTION IN HISTORY.
51 MILLION BALLOTS SENT TO
PEOPLE.
MANY WILL HAVE BEEN DEAD.
MANY WILL GET MORE THAN ONE.
IT WILL BE A HORRIBLE THING.
JUST A HORRIBLE THING.
IT’S IMPOSSIBLE.
A CONGRESSWOMAN WHO IS NOT
A VERY GOOD ONE ON THE EAST SIDE
OF MANHATTAN.
THAT WAS SO MESSED UP FOR WEEKS
AND THEY JUST DECLARED HER
A WINNER BUT THEY HAVE NO IDEA
WHERE THE BALLOTS ARE.
IT’S A DISASTER IN NEW JERSEY.
AND VIRGINIA -- WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THINGS THAT JUST TOOK
PLACE.
SMALL ELECTIONS RELATIVELY.
NOW THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
SENDING 51 BALLOTS OUT TO
ANYBODY -- NOBODY KNOWS WHO WILL
GET THEM.
IT’S A HORRIBLE THING.
IT’S A FRAUDULENT ELECTION.
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT.
51 MILLION BALLOTS WILL BE SENT
OUT.
TO PEOPLE THAT DIDN’T EVEN ASK
FOR THEM.
PEOPLE SAY I JUST GOT A BALLOT.
THAT’S GREAT.
LET ME VOTE.
IT’S A TERRIBLE THING.
THEY ARE TRYING TO STEAL THE
ELECTION.
>> Sean: DR. FAUCI SAID IT WOULD
BE SAFE WITH SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND MASKS FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE IN
PERSON.
THIS IS THE DNC WEEK.
I HAVE BEEN ON FOX 25 YEARS.
IF I WAS AT THE DNC EVERY YEAR
INCLUDING YOUR LAST ELECTION, I
HAD TO HAVE A PICTURE I.D. TO
GET IN THE BUILDING.
I WAS CHECKED EVERY NIGHT.
I WAS PROBABLY DOUBLE CHECKED.
KIDDING.
TO GET IN THE BUILDING AM MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS,ARE YOU GOING
TO HAVE POLL WATCHERS?
WILL YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO
MONITOR, TO AVOID FRAUD AND
CROSS CHECK WHETHER OR NOT THESE
ARE REGISTERED VOTERS?
WHETHER OR NOT THERE IS
IDENTIFICATION TO KNOW IT’S
A REAL VOTE?
>> WE WILL HAVE EVERYTHING.
SHERIFFS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
U.S. ATTORNEYS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERALS.
BUT IT’S VERY HARD.
YOU HAVE SOME OF THESE STATES
SENDING THEM OUT LIKE NEVADA
WHERE THEY DON’T HAVE TO CHECK
THE SIGNATURE SO ANYBODY CAN
SIGN IT.
THE NEW JERSEY GOVERNOR JUST
SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER TO GET
IT DONE.
NOBODY HAS EVER HEARD OF
ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
THEY WILL SEND OUT 51 MILLION
BALLOTS TO PEOPLE THEY HAVE NO
IDEA WHY IT’S COMING, WHO IT’S
GOING TO.
UNFORTUNATELY THEY MAY HAVE
A VERY GOOD IDEA THE PEOPLE
SENDING THEM.
THEY MAY SEND THEM TO ALL
DEMOCRAT AREAS AND NOT TO
REPUBLICAN AREAS.
IT COULD BE THE OTHER WAY TOO,
BUT I DOUBT IT.
IT’S A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM.
A LOT OF TIMES YOU DON’T EVEN
HAVE TO SEND IT BACK UNTIL AFTER
THE ELECTION.
ON NOVEMBER 3rd, WE ARE USED TO
HEAR TRUMP WON THE ELECTION AND
YOU SAW HAPPY HILLARY’S PEOPLE
WERE, THEY WERE THRILLED WHEN I
WON.
>> Sean: I GOT AN EMERGENCY
CALL.
CALL INTO FOX NOW.
>> Sean: SHE ASKED ME WILL YOU
SUPPORT THE DECISION OF THE
VOTERS?
>> SHE IS WALKING AROUND SAYING
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Sean: IS IT TRUE, KAYLEIGH
MCENANY YOUR PRESS SECRETARY
SAID YOUR ADMINISTRATION JUST
OFFERED $10 MILLION FOR THE U.S.
POSTAL SERVICE BEFORE THE
DEMOCRATS WENT ON RECESS AND
THEY TURNED IT DOWN?
>> THERE IS NO TROUBLE IS THE
POSTAL SERVICE.
THEY WILL DO A GOOD JOB.
IT’S NOT THE POSTAL SERVICE.
IT’S WHAT HAPPENS TO THESE
BALLOTS WHEN THEY ARE SENT?
WHO ARE THESE 51 MILLION BALLOTS
BEING SENT TO?
WHO DETERMINES WHERE THEY ARE
SENT TO.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT MASSIVE
NUMBERS.
THEY COULD NOT DO CAROL MALONEY
WHO SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO ACCEPT
THAT POSITION.
THEY DECLARED A WINNER OVER
A GUY WHO IS SAYING WHAT
HAPPENED?
HE THOUGHT HE WON.
THEY TORBOT THAT ELECTION OVER
AGAIN IN MANHATTAN.
IT’S A DISGRACE.SHOULD DO THAT E
OVER AGAIN IN MANHATTAN.
IT’S A DISGRACE.
THAT WAS A SMALL ELECTION.
51 MILLION ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
THEY WILL SEND THEM TO WHOEVER
SEND THOSE BALLOTS, IS A VERY
POWERFUL PERSON.
AND ON THE ASSUMPTION THAT THE
PERSON IS HONEST, IT WILL STILL
BE FRAUGHT WITH ERROR.
EVEN IF SOMEBODY WAS HONEST
BECAUSE PEOPLE DIE AND OTHER
PEOPLE SEE IT AND GRAB IT AND
SIGN IT AND SEND IT BACK.